All right Charles let's see what you think.
>> The first one says we want to have
a fixed number of clusters. Well actually the first thing
I'll note about that, since we're going to have a
fixed number of clusters in doesn't have the richness property.
>> Good point.
>> Because richness would allow for one cluster or it could have
n clusters or it could have n over three clusters or it
could have n over two clusters. But here you forced it to
always have n over two clusters so it can't represent all possible clusters.
>> Agreed.
>> However, you'll notice that there's nothing
in here that cares about distances. In the sense
that, if I took all of the coints, and
I multiplied their distances by two, I would still
get the same clusters in exactly the same order.
>> That's the important thing. That it cares about distancees
but it only cares about the order not the scale.
>> Exactly. So that means there's scale-invariance.
>> Very good.
>> And then by the same argument, this algorithm has consistency because the
points that were, clustered together if they
got closer together, they would still be
picked up. And the ones that were farther apart, well, they'd still get
picked up by each other and it,
it doesn't matter. So they're definitely consistent.
>> That's right. And it's a nice little property of
single-link clustering. Let's move on to the second clustering algorithm.
>> Nice. Okay so clusters that are theta units
apart, well, since theta can change, even if theta's
fixed the, the points that I get. Could be
various kinds of distances. So, let's imagine that theta
was ten feet. If all the points are within ten
feet of one another, then they would be one cluster.
>> Yup.
>> If on the other hand, all the
points were more than ten feet apart, you would
have N different clusters. And, you could do
any of them in between. So, this is rich.
>> It is indeed. That's right. We can always
muck with the units. Or muck with theta for
that matter. So, that we can group the beginning
of our clusters in any. Accommodation that we want.
>> Yeah, but for exactly the same argument that they're
rich, they're not scale invariant.
>> Yeah.
>> Because I could just take everything and multiply it by theta,
multiply it by the distance by theta and now I will suddenly have
n then if I had n to begin with, I could divide
by theta, and then I would have one. So it's not scale invariant.
>> Agreed.
>> But the consistency argument still works, because all the
points that got clustered together. Because they're within theta of each
other. If I made them closer, would still be within
theta of each other. And the ones that weren't closer together
because they were more than theta apart, would now be
even more theta apart and so you do get consistency.
>> Agreed.
>> Excellent. Ok.
>> Alright, last example.
>> Clusters that are Theta W units apart
where. I'm sorry, Theta Omega units apart. [LAUGH]
>> Theta divided by Omega.
>> Yeah.
>> Where Omega equals the maximum distance. Well, that's just
a way of normalizing distance. In much the same way
that I argued for richness of the
second algorithm, the same argument applies here.
>> That it is rich.
>> It is rich, because I can just keep shrinking and moving the
points around, and it will work out just fine. And so, it's definitely rich.
>> We don't control omega, because that's determined
by the distances, but we can change the
theta so that things are too close or too far. Yeah, okay, I agree with that.
>> That's sort of the last thing you said for the
second algorithm too. So you do get richness. Now, what's interesting
to me here is that unlike in the second algorithm where you didn't have
scale and variance, you do get scale and variance here because if I try to
make things bigger. I'm also going to
make the maximum distance bigger by exactly
the same amount and so I will always end up back where I was before.
>> Yeah. So whatever you do to scale
this, it's going to get undone. Yeah. Very good.
>> Right. Exactly. Anything I do to make it, make
them far apart will just make them the same distance.
But at least by omega.
>> Agreed. Okay. And, and if we have consistency too, we've got a trifecta.
>> We do, except, we don't have consistency.
>> What?
>> Because if I make the, the clusters that
are farther apart, farther apart, then I also change omega.
>> And that could actually change the cluster.
>> It would because, in fact, imagine that I made the
points in a set of clusters. Much closer together, but then
I move that cluster, you know, sort of infinitely far apart
from the rest of the clusters. Then, suddenly my theta divided by
infinity, or near infinity, would make the, the
radius of allowable clusters so small that no
points would be able to cluster with any other point. And so that would screw up
whatever you had before, assuming you had clusters
before at all. And so, I can construct
a world where consistency would be wrong. Oh
that's nice, it made a little diagonal of X's.
>> [LAUGH] And I win, three in a row.
>> Well done Michael. So, what little tweak do we
have to do to these algorithms to get a trifecta?
>> Yeah,
that would be great, wouldn't it? And
that's the final algorithm that we'll talk about.
>> Great.